bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une vidéo j'essayais pas longtemps sur
la playstation 5
c'est une vidéo qui a eu effectivement
beaucoup d'engouement beaucoup de
commentaires et je suis ça serait pas
mal de pouvoir répondre à ces
commentaires de façon constructive
rassurez vous donc on va faire ça à
petit
[Musique]
l'appel 5 c'est vrai que c'est la
console qui est énormément attendu
l'année dernière microsoft a sorti sa
xbox ou vannes x la console
actuellement la plus puissante au monde
effectivement il ya eu plusieurs rumeurs
sur la possible arrivée d'une
playstation 5 cette année voire
peut-être l'année prochaine
il ya plein d'infos contradictoires il
ya plein de choses intéressantes et
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient super
intéressant c'était de voir tous les
messages que vous m'avez laissé ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on m'a regardé
ensemble les commentaires alors y en a
eu énormément et je veux pas vous dire
de bêtises mais je crois que dans cette
vidéo vous avez 573 a commenté autant de
dire que ça fait beaucoup de monde a
répondu on va vraiment se faire un petit
condensé des choses et des idées que
j'ai vu revenir régulièrement parce que
je pense qu'il ya plein de choses
intéressantes sur cette ps5
non pas seulement pour parler de l'objet
en lui même mais tout simplement pour
pouvoir parler du concept même et de
l'évolution des consoles en règle
générale du jeu en règle générale mais
du gaming
donc ça va je trouve ça c'est super
intéressant enfin du gaming en tout cas
sur consoles je vois pas la clé 5 sortir
avant septembre 2019 voire 2020 car la
ps4 a toujours les armes pour rivaliser
que la xbox one x alors c'est très clair
que de toute façon si ça pèse 5 arrive à
priori en 2018 ça va être un petit peu
juste parce qu'à une info de shawn
linden qui est le seuil haut de sony usa
mais que c'est président de sony
interactive entertainment pour une voire
studio aux accents est un peu compliquée
qui a annoncé dans une interview à goal
m.de que effectivement la ps1 qu il
travaillait dessus mais pas pour tout de
suite
ça c'est une interview qui date du mois
de juin 2010 est donc il ya quand même
quelques bons actuellement on imagine
que pour pas tout de suite ça veut pas
dire dans quelques mois mais dans un an
dans un an et demi deux ans deux ans et
demi on peut très bien la voir arriver
donc pour moi cette vidéo effectivement
pour pouvoir parler de l'arrivée de la
ps 5 pourquoi pas fin 2018 ça pourrait
avoir un sens ça ne font peut-être un
petit peu tôt fin 2018 après une fois de
plus ce que je voulais dans ce type de
vidéos ce sont des rumeurs et des infos
non pas des rumeurs que je vais inventer
moi parce que je les sors pas de mon
chapeau et aucune prétention dans ce
domaine là mais tout simplement parce
qu'il ya des analystes qui connaissent
la culture l'entreprise qui connaissent
les
produits qui connaissent les dates de
sorties qui ont fait une analyse
complète par rapport au marché par
rapport à la concurrence
pour pouvoir vous dire à quel moment ils
estiment que ce produit en tout cas l
aps 5 pourrait sortir et c'est vraiment
tout l'intérêt de cette typologie de
vidéos de pouvoir un petit peu se sentir
ce qui va arriver alors peut-être
qu'elle arrivera par fin 2018 peut-être
que 2019 peut-être 2020 mais en tout cas
ce qui est sûr ce qui est sûr et certain
c'est que la ps 5 va arriver pour moi
pas vendre mi 2010 neuf car c'est
stupide de sortir une nouvelle console à
avoir que la ps4 se vend bien la ps4 pro
surtout que c'est vrai que la ps4 trop
fonctionne bien elle est plus la console
la plus puissante au monde depuis que la
xbox est sorti mais en tout cas on va
très bien que pour l'europe playstation
est une marque est très très forte
un petit peu moins aux états unis donc à
une vraie rivalité des continents si on
peut dire ça comme ça mais c'est vrai
que en tout cas la ps4 pro pour
l'instant encore de nos jours devant
elle
je pense que monsieur tong le mans ce
temps tu vois juste y en a qui sont
d'accord avec en tout cas les rumeurs de
fin 2018 il faudrait attendre dans les
environs de 2021 2024 et dans l'intérêt
des joueurs c'est mieux que d'acheter
une version qui se ressemblent trop à
l'ancienne ouais alors je suis pas sûr
que la paix 5 ressemble exactement la
ps4 alors à plus de puissance des
capacités vidéo des capacités audio qui
sont vraiment rock
à mon avis on sera vraiment dans autre
chose aucune chance que ça sorte
maintenant j'ai vu que sony avait dit au
moins 2020 car ils peuvent encore faire
de super jeu xbox one-x peut-être plus
puissante mais les jeux ne sont pas
aussi bons que ça j'ai pas vu moi que
sony annoncé qu'il sortirait rien avant
2020 sony a dit oui mais pas tout de
suite et ils ont dit ça il ya quasiment
un an dont bon c'est encore très très
floue tout ça il n'y a pas de date
précise et c'est ça qui est un peu un
peu délicat michael patcher est un grand
guignol franchement serait plus un clown
khan analyste à la tête le prendre au
sérieux et nous annoncer que des fausses
rumeurs ce type on voit que là pour le
coup chacun qui ne crois pas trop aux
prédictions de michael patcher avec les
grosses exclus sony en 2018 ça serait ça
serait débile de leur part de la sortir
cette année
ça paraît effectivement logique de ce
directeur qui vont prononcer des
produits des exclus de la ps4 pro on
peut dire qu'il apaise 5 va pas arriver
de notre côté lorsqu'une nouvelle
console arrive ça veut pas dire qu'on
arrête de faire des grosses des gros
jeux pour l'ancienne console même si je
peux me tromper je continue à croire
qu'ils auront une rétro compatibilité
entre la presse 5 et la ps4
trop en tout cas ça me paraît être
plutôt logique
je vu le marché actuel je pense que
l'appel 5 doit sortir en 2020 non pas
2018 ce sera 2020 et pas mal de monde
qui pense qu'elle peut sortir ans en
2020 d'ailleurs vous dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
pourquoi ces cas-là sortir quand cette
console va sortir un moment ou un autre
elle aura une forme will not mais elle
va sortir
vous pensez qu'elle va sortir qu'en fin
2018 2019 2020
arkema son commentaire bon encore des
mois de seconde le temps de me
rafraîchir un peu la tronche
il revient bon ça va mieux on continue
30 le duc qui nous dit hello moi qui ai
parlé avec une responsable de sony jeu
vidéo aujourd'hui à la fnac
elle m'a dit pape et 5 pour 2018 mais
une console avec un autre nom
s'intéressant à rester connectés aussi
là dessus on l'a on parle de huit cas 4k
il ya aussi un espèce de débat autour
effectivement la définition pour avoir
cette console la capca c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas encore complètement
démocratise et ça on le voit tout le
monde n'est pas équipés de téléviseur 4k
mais on voit que les caps les écrans
quelques à vous montrer encore plus dans
les foyers dans les temps à venir
la nuit quand on n'y est pas encore du
tout alors effectivement parler de
consoles vicat mise à part ajoute un peu
plus de fluidité sur des écrans quatre
cas mais des écrans huit cas vous n'avez
pas les abords toulouse demain chez vous
en tout cas donc pour l'instant la 8 cas
on parle pas encore concernant le prix
il ya paul valéry qui dit je vois mal
sony en train de fabriquer une console
qui va coûter dans les 500 euros
la politique d'un prix réduit leur a
plutôt bien réussi à la sortie de la ps4
donc selon moi sony va viser la sortie
d'une nouvelle console avec un tarif
toujours dans les 400 euros c'est
effectivement points qui étaient
beaucoup abordé la question du prix moi
je pense de toute façon que ses consoles
elles vont coûter cher au point de vue
fabrication et de
recherche-développement et puis par
rapport au prix du marché il est délicat
de sortir une console peu cher peu chez
arthur des guillemets parce que même 400
euros sur une console sera quand même un
petit budget après la question que je me
pose c'est la console aujourd'hui telle
qu'on la connaît c'est à dire du
hardware avec une carte graphique avec
un processeur avec un disque dur avec un
lecteur de blu-ray oui non la console
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui c'est
une console matériel physique avec des
jeux physiques
on voit qu'il ya une vraie évolution au
niveau du jeu vidéo pour que le jeu
vidéo soit de plus en plus dématérialisé
donc ça c'est aussi un poids qui peut
être très intéressant c'est là un point
sur lequel travaille d'ailleurs
microsoft pouvoir proposer du
je sens support vous vous connectez à
internet vous à vous pouvez jouer sur
n'importe quelle diva est ce que ce soit
un portable une télé un ordinateur une
tablette
vous n'avez pas besoin de console vous
avez juste besoin d'une bonne connexion
internet une connexion adsl marche sera
très bien de la fibre c'est encore mieux
la 4g ça fonctionnera très très bien et
là dessus vous aurez effectivement plus
du tout besoin de console d'une
application et vous aurez accès à un
catalogue donc on peut très bien
imaginer que microsoft vous sortent ça
bientôt sony vous sortent une console
complètement dématérialisé alors ce qui
est un petit peu embêtant dans tout ça
c'est effectivement de se dire une
console entièrement dématérialisé une
console dans le cloud pourquoi pas mais
est ce que vous auriez la même puissance
est là à priori oui imaginez on reprend
par exemple une vidéo j'ai fait y'a pas
longtemps la vidéo sur les ordinateurs
dans le club shadow de blade si vous
avez suivi d'ailleurs si vous connaissez
y en a plein qui connaissent déjà
shadows un ordinateur vous avez votre pc
sous windows 10 qui est dans le cloud
donc vous avez un petit abonnement
mensuel vous payez et vous avez accès à
votre machine
quel que soit le device et ce qui est
génial là dedans c'est de se dire que
nous bien que la technologie avance
évolué et qui est des cartes mères
toujours plus puissants des processeurs
plus puissants
vous bénéficierez toujours de la
meilleure technologie pour votre bécane
on peut imaginer la même chose pour du
gaming imaginez par exemple pour la ps 5
chambres ont effectivement on parle dans
des spéculations mais pour la paix s 5
imaginez que sony vous dise je vous sors
pas une console hardware je vous sors
une console dans le corps
c'est à dire que vous n'aurez pas votre
bécane mais par contre vous pourrez
jouer à vos jeux sur votre ordi vous
pourrez jouer à votre jeu sur votre
smartphone
il faut il juste que vous ayez une bonne
bande passante pour pouvoir en profiter
les mêmes sur votre télé vous branchez
vous avez la fibre vous jouez sur une
télé cap cas avec une résolution 4k ça
peut paraître fou mais à mon avis c'est
là dessus qu'on va aussi se diriger
alors la question c'est est-ce que la
paix 5 sera une console dans le club ou
alors est-ce que ça restera une console
physique avec des jeux dématérialisés
ça c'est aussi possibilité d'ailleurs
dit pas ce que vous en pensez parce que
je pense que la question se pose aussi
en sens effectivement la question de
date de sortie
effectivement la question du prix mais
il ya la question même donné
distance de la console et de quel type
de console on va voir est-ce qu'on va
garder une console avec vraiment
hardware défini avec des jeux physiques
qu'on va me remettre dedans des titres
qu'on va me réinsérer dedans ou alors
est ce qu'on va voir des jeux
dématérialisés et pourquoi pas une
console complètement dématérialisé dit
pas ce que vous en pensez parce que ça
on en a pas beaucoup parlé et je pense
que c'est un vrai sujet hyper pertinent
à matt clash
j'aime bien ça ça troll un peu tu es un
peu vieux pour un gamer mais tu t'y
connais c'est cool ouais si tu veux le
le truc qui a c'est que je peux pas
affecté mon un petit peu vieux avec mes
cheveux blancs mais ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que ce fait partie des
premiers gamer la première console je l'
ai connus quand lé sortir sa frappe de
dinosaures parler comme ça mais les
premiers jeux j'ai joué sur mon ordi mon
amstrad cpc 464 à cassette le jeu vidéo
quand je l' ai connu c'est est-ce que
vous est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui du
retrogaming donc très clairement la nes
je les ai vus sortir la super nintendo
n'en parlons pas et la première
playstation j'ai eu donc effectivement
point de vue playstation 2 point de vue
console c'est quelque chose que j'ai
quand même côtoyé dès le départ dont se
dire que même si j'ai lâché un petit peu
ces derniers temps je n'y connais un peu
quand même partie on pourra sur un peu
tout le monde
y a pas d'âge pour jouer voilà ça c'est
ça c'est le bon le bon mot c'est n'y a
pas d'âge pour jouer
tiens il ya un commentaire intéressant
de ryan warriors
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant le
cloud gaming mais malheureusement il
faut une collection ultra rapide oui et
non parce que j'ai pu en parler je me
répète je ne dois pas reine en quelques
vidéos j'ai parlé avec les créateurs de
black note qu' un peu le le jeu vidéo
dans le cloud qui devrait arriver
bientôt d'ailleurs si vous allez vous si
vous voulez allez voir je vous mets le
lien de la vidéo ici
ce qui est super intéressant avec le jeu
vidéo dans le cloud c'est que vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir une collection
dingue un adsl ou une quête j'ai ça
suffit largement
par contre effectivement si vous vous
retrouvez avec une connexion qui
baissent vous n'allez pas voir un jeu
qui va la guerre au sens micro coupures
ou coupées vous y retrouvez avec un jeu
comme sur youtube avec une qualité
d'affichage qui va descendre le cloud
gaming c'est vraiment l'avenir du
vidéo grand public je vous parle pas de
jeux vidéo de gamer avec des machines
hyper puissante sur des choses comme ça
je vous parle de gaming de consoles de
gaming tout un chacun avec un smartphone
ça va continuer le cloud gaming a
démocratisé le jeu vidéo pour que tout
le monde puisse jouer partout et tout le
temps commentaire de sss cas officiel je
veux pas regarder la vidéo car rien que
le titre à un problème elle ne pourra
pas être la plus puissant de 2018 car
elle ne va pas sortir cette année
arrêtez de faire des vidéos de mer
[ __ ] clic le pire c'est que le mec il
a facile 30 35 ans grandit un peu non
j'ai 38 ans ok bon je pense mais je suis
assez grand mais si tu veux ce que je
veux dire avec ce genre de vidéos c'est
pas des vidéos plus ta clique c'est pas
des vidéos où je vais dire de la merde
cd vidéo dans lequel on va essayer de
sentir des tendances de sentir à marcher
et d'essayer de voir ce qui va se
dessiner ce qui va arriver que je fais
d'ailleurs ce genre de vidéos sur du
smartphone sur des objets tech mais sur
la console parce que pour moi c'est un
vrai sens c'est de se poser la question
d'un marché à un instant t
parce qu'effectivement sony peut faire
des plans il ya aussi il faut aussi
tenir compte de la concurrence
en l'occurrence de microsoft et de sony
qui sont quand même des poids lourds sur
le marché donc ce type de vidéo c'est
pas de la vidéo puis ta clique pour
choper de la vue choper du commentaire
choper du clic
l'intérêt c'est effectivement de se
poser des questions par rapport à
l'évolution par rapport à l'avenir du
jeu vidéo parce que même si dans la
vidéo je me base sur des analystes moi
je ne suis pas un analyste je vais pas
effectivement avoir les capacités
d'analysé ce marché je n'ai aucunement
je n'ai pas du tout la prétention il ya
des gens derrière qui ont des
compétences ils peuvent se complètement
se tromper mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder où on en est à un
instant t et qu'après on puisse en
discuter ensemble je dis pas que ce que
je dis dans la vidéo est une vérité je
ne dis pas que cette console va sortir
en 2018 je soulève la question à
l'instant t
par rapport aux connaissances qu'on a
est ce qu'on peut penser que cette
console va sortir en 2018 et 6000 sort
en 2018 à quoi il va ressembler et
est-ce qu'elle met une grande claque à
la xbox onyx et c'est ça qui est super
intéressant parce que si on suit ce
raisonnement ça voudrait dire que dès
lors qui a pas d'annoncé officielle et
qui a pas d'infos officielles
on ne peut pas en parler on peut pas
spéculer on peut pas se poser les
questions et essayer de sentir essayer
de deviner ce qui va se passer à
l'avenir que ce soit sur du smartphone
ou sur de la console ou sur n'importe
quel autre domaine
pour moi la vidéo sur la ps 5 est sorti
d'ailleurs comme celle
et aulas ont un intérêt elles nous
permettent d'échanger de partager
peut-être qu'à des sources et des infos
qui m'ont échappé et à ce moment là je
vous invite à bien marquer en
commentaire parce que ça me permet à moi
d'avoir ces infos de les lire et de me
renseigner dort plus d'infos parce que
je dis pas que je peux être partout et à
tous les passionnés également de pouvoir
en avoir connaissance
donc voila un petit peu l'idée ça c'est
bien parce que il faut pas croire que ce
type de vidéos ne sert à rien pour moi
en tout cas c'est un sens rose 2.0 je
pense qu'ils vont l'annoncer en
septembre et la vendre en décembre
gardiens ce commentaire en mémoire comme
ça c'est s'officialiser tu me le diras
tu as aussi je le note l'has coup
alexandre des bêtes la place 5 va sortir
en 2020 espèce de nuls va un nom il ya
aucune info sports une sortie de la ps 5
en 2020 ça c'est pareil c'est la
spéculation
christopher théveny il n'y aura pas de
paix 5 c'est christopher y aura une ps5
après on sait pas à quoi il va
ressembler mais il y aura eu ps5 greg
titre de mère l'appelle cinq soirs en
2020 minimum renseigne toi bordel ben
oui c'est ce que je fais et je me
renseigne on ne sait pas s'il appelle 5
son tir en 2020 on sait qu'elle sortira
en juin de l'année dernière ils ont dit
pas tout de suite
n'est elle va sortir ça veut pas dire
qu'à sortir en 2020 désolé l'appel 5e'
pas comme sa mito bah oui parce que j'ai
mis une image c cnet c'est une création
d'artistes la ps5
effectivement comme l est pas sorti on
sait pas à quoi elle ressemblera joris
landry [ __ ] mais arrêtez de parler de
la ps1 qu'elle est même pas encore sorti
lé même pas encore annoncé mais oui mais
c'est ce que faisait tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que l'appel 5
comme tous les produits qui sont pas
annoncés on peut quand même en parler
pour essayer de sentir et de voir ce que
ça va donner ce que je vais vraiment de
vos commentaires et merci beaucoup à ce
que vous êtes super nombreux c'est
génial vous jouez le jeu c'est top
ce que je vois vraiment c'est la date de
sortie sur laquelle on n'est plus sûr du
2019 2020
on est plus à se poser des questions sur
quelle console sera la piste entre la
xbox one xl aps 5
il ya des vraies guerres de clochers
face à dépend des goûts de chacun il y
en a sont plus microsoft d'autres qui
sont plus sony y en a qui se posent des
questions sur l'a4 kahui cas y en a qui
parle effectivement de cloud gaming
il ya vraiment un peu tout c'est toutes
ces questions toutes ces interrogations
là bon il y en a énormément j'ai
vraiment fait un tour complet je pense
en tout cas merci à tous d'avoir été
très très très nombreux à commenter
j'espère que vous soit tout autant
commenter celle-là parce que le débat
reste ouvert je pense que c'est toujours
intéressant effectivement déjà de
pouvoir discuter de pouvoir échanger de
pouvoir moi en tout cas lire tous vos
commentaires de pouvoir on apprend que
j'apprends plein de choses à travers vos
commentaires je suis pas le spécialiste
du jeu vidéo loin de là donc je suis
hyper content parce que grâce aussi à
vous j'apprends des choses
j'espère que vous en apprenez grâce à
mes vidéos au moins en tout cas grâce à
vos commentaires je m'enrichis
énormément merci beaucoup merci d'être
là toujours plus nombreux comme d'hab je
vous invite à vous abonner parce qu'on
va parler toujours plus de teck de
produits influent ancien pas achement de
choses qui vont arriver dans les temps à
venir donc rester connecté si cette
vidéo vous intéresser sujet vous
intéresse si michel vous intéresse je
vous invite à me laisser des jolies
pouces on reste bien évidemment
connectés je donne rendez-vous d'ici
quelques jours vous donnent rendez vous
très très rapidement parce qu'on va
parler de plein de choses tech hyper
cool je vais partir au mwc et vous allez
voir ailleurs pour l'un exclut sur les
nouveaux smartphones on va les voir les
grosses tendances voire un petit peu ce
qui va se passer cette année
essai de renifler tendances de l'année
prochaine donc restez connectés merci
beaucoup
soyez sages à très bientôt bisous bisous
bisous
[Musique]